ah yes the P tape he tape it's possible
Jim it's possible and it's possible
Martian Martians will we're in that room
peeing on the prostitutes - that sick
liberal fantasy I can't stop I mean they
can't stop thinking about I went to rush
on business I love it there and I
especially love the prostitutes
um Donald do you like high-powered
businessman I did good I want you to
call one of your prostitute friends told
her to bring over a bunch of bottles of
water I want to fill your blood or
tsubame stayed here once I want to use
the tile at the Obama is no you pee on
the bed the bad world bomb a slob I hate
Obama so long okay here comes the tea
good god that's a lot of people what's
that coming out of the shadows
ah it's aliens get out of here you were
aliens wait unless you also want to pee
on the bed will Obama
oh my god they're peeing on us the
aliens are peeing a new european on the
bed with god that's a lot of pee Oh
someone's been recording this whole
thing I'm still peeing I hope no one
tries to blackmail me with this yeah
that's exactly how it all went down
sick livers